wir zeigen ihnen jetzt bilder die um die
welt gehen die auch zeigen wie stark der
ukrainische widerstand ist hier rollt
ein putin panzer an eine gruppe von
unbewaffneten zivilisten stellt sich
diesen panzer entgegen an vorderster
front steht der bürgermeister einer
stadt in der südlichen zentral ukraine
die putin einnehmen will dann das
unfassbare der panzer dreht ist der
panzer sich zurückzieht rufen die männer
ruhm der ukraine
slava ukraine unbewaffnete männer die
sich da auf der straße den russischen
panzern herstellen und dieser panzer
zumindest der tritt ab
aber wir wollen wir sprechen studio über
diesen moment wort freiheit mit dem
springer vorstandsvorsitzende mathias
döpfner herzlich willkommen bei bett lag
am morgen dieser geist der freiheit
diese beeindruckenden szenen das ist
natürlich ein ganz kleiner ausschnitt
aus diesen tagen aus der ukraine aber
ist das ein symbol in hinweis darauf
dass am ende eben doch die freiheit
siegen wird gegen waffen
es ist auf jeden fall ein unglaublich
bewegendes bild eine bewegende szene und
natürlich auch eine symbolische szene
und wir hoffen dass das die botschaft
ist die dann auch eintritt auf jeden
fall zeigt es doch aber auch das
offenbar in den köpfen der soldaten die
in diesen sinnlosen krieg geschickt
werden etwas passiert und sie vielleicht
sagen wir wollen uns eben nicht einfach
benutzen lassen um ihr unsere unser
bruder volkswirt zusagen zu ermorden
also auch insofern sehr sehr ermutigend
und ja ich glaube im moment wird
eigentlich mit jeder stunde die
wahrscheinlichkeit etwas höher dass
putin sich verkalkuliert hat und für sie
ist ja diese freiheit für die die
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer kämpfen nicht
nur deren freiheit es ist unser aller
freiheit ich bin fest davon überzeugt
dass hier ist unwesentlich mehr geht als
um die freiheit der ukraine es geht
wirklich um umwelt ordnung es geht um
die frage ob freie demokratische
gesellschaften offene gesellschaften
stark sind sich auch im widerstand gegen
autokraten und diktatoren
wirklich selbstbewusst und erfolgreich
aufstellen können und das war nicht
immer sicher und ich glaube aber dass
die entwicklungen der letzten tage hier
wirklich unglaublich positiv zu bewerten
sind und ich muss sagen ich bin auch
persönlich sehr
beeindruckt wie eigentlich über alle
parteipolitischen grenzen hinweg von
rechts bis links diese dinge gemeinsam
gesehen werden nur die extreme die
linksextreme und die rechtsextremen die
haben eben schon immer ein anderes
weltbild gehabt und da schon in eine
andere nähe zur freiheitlichen figuren
und
autokraten gehabt aber alle
demokratischen parteien in deutschland
in europa und in amerika weltweit
eigentlich halten hier in diesem moment
zusammen und senden sehr starke signale
die deutsche politik hat in wenigen
tagen absolute grundarchitektur
aspekte ihrer langjährigen außen und
sicherheitspolitik verändert plötzlich
wollen wir waffen liefern gott sei dank
um unsere
freunde in der ukraine zu schützen und
ihnen zu helfen
plötzlich wollen wir die bundeswehr
tüchtigen mit 100 milliarden plötzlich
wollen wir unsere nato verpflichtung
erfüllen das sind alles unglaublich
richtige entwicklung und ich finde wenn
man jetzt kleinkariert kritisiert zu
spät hat man früher wissen müssen ja
aber es war ja auch über jahre und
jahrzehnte anders und diese regierung
hat jetzt hier in deutschland sehr
schnell etwas anders gemacht und das
finde ich verdient unsere bewunderung
plötzlich ist die ukraine und nicht weit
weg so wie man monatelang wochen lang
bei vielen deutschen bei der regierung
auch den eindruck hatte hunderttausend
waren hier in berlin gestern auf der
straße der botschafter der ukraine
andrej melik wurde gestern ja mit
stehenden ovationen
beklatscht dort im bundestag minuten
lang und gleichzeitig sie haben gerade
gesagt der beschluss eben ja zu
waffenlieferungen jetzt doch in der
ukraine eine massive aufstockung des
verteidigungshaushaltes von 100
milliarden euro obendrauf von olaf
scholz versprochen heißt dass wir sind
erwachsen geworden außenpolitischer es
ja ich glaube genau das heißt dass das
fing ja mit einem grünen außenminister
joschka fischer an damals auf dem balkan
wo man zum ersten mal sagte vielleicht
ist diese lektion die wir aus der
deutschen geschichte aus dem holocaust
gelernt haben eben nicht zu sagen nie
wieder militärische intervention sondern
vielleicht ist die bessere und richtige
reaktion nie wieder völkermord nie
wieder rassismus nie wieder peace and
gegenüber diktatoren und das ist im
grunde jetzt im zweiten entscheidenden
kapitel das was auch wieder eine grüne
außenministerin hier vollendet oder
weiterführt insofern ist das schon sehr
bewegender und historischer
moment und man kann es so formulieren ja
wir sind erwachsen geworden sind
sozusagen zeiten des ernstes eingetreten
die jedem vor augen führen dass
bestimmte naive weltbilder wir müssen
nur nette kompromisse anbieten und uns
raushalten dann wird alles gut dass das
eben nicht funktioniert ich glaube es
wird jetzt irgendwann auch noch auf die
diskussion des letzten großen themas
hinaus laufen nämlich in der
energiepolitik haben wir doch
feststellen müssen dass wir uns durch
den atomausstieg von russland abhängig
gemacht haben und damit auch von
russischer politik und die bittere
lektion lernen wir jetzt gerade jetzt
ist die frage was folgt daraus und ich
glaube für oder später wird auch über
atomenergie noch mal nachgedacht werden
müssen nicht nur aus
sicherheitspolitischen gründen und
gründen der unabhängigkeit sondern
natürlich auch um die klimaziele zu
erfüllen also ich glaube da kommt noch
die nächste große diskussion die
vielleicht etwas schwieriger werden wird
in dieser regierungskonstellation aber
ich glaube auch die diskussion muss
geführt werden erst der impulse für
diese diskussionen sind auf jeden fall
schon gesetzt das kann man ganz klar
sagen springer chef mathias döpfner
vielen herzlichen dank für ihren besuch
hier bei uns im studio gegangen